- We used to go to topless bars.
Strip shows.
- What?
I had no idea
that you used to do that.
- I was fun, I liked it.
- Fatherhood!
It's Father's Day, comin' up soon.
- [Zach] About two years ago, the Try Guys
made a motherhood series for mother's day.
- [Keith] So we're doing
a whole fatherhood series.
- One video every day
that's all about dads.
(crying)
- Uh oh.
- Is it rude for me to
say that I want out?
- The Try Guys are
going to become fathers.
We're gonna become daddies.
Or at least invite our dads to come in
from across the nation to let us know
how terrible it was to raise us.
(upbeat music)
- So today we're recreating
photos of our dads.
- In an aim to better
understand who they were
when they were our age.
- I think many times, the
father/son relationship
is the least developed in the family.
- His life starts when I was born.
- But before that he's just like us?
- I don't really know a ton about my dad,
which is why we wanted
to do this whole series.
- Let's get daddy-ied.
Daddies.
- It's weird.
There some photos I look at my dad
and I'm like, "I don't
recognize that man."
And there's some photos I'm like,
"Wow, that's my face."
I doubt he knows what
day this photo was taken,
but my dad is rockin' a mean porn-'stache.
Is it weird to call your
dad's 'stache a porn-'stache?
It's a porn-'stache.
I think my dad and I are really
similar in a lot of ways.
My dad and I talk about music
and we talk about football
and that's kinda it.
When I check in with my parents about how
my life is going, I call my mom.
I wanna get advice from him,
and we don't do that.
I know my mom always says
that my dad was funny.
I don't see it.
Apparently that's how my dad won my mom
and god knows if I find somebody
that's gonna be how I do it.
- A lot of my memories are
playing outside with my dad.
So my dad is a doctor, but he kind of
took some time to figure that out.
He was actually a tennis pro for a while.
I always think of my
dad as a clean cut guy.
His hair is long.
My dad has never had long hair.
I definitely got my
competitive nature from my dad.
We would play a lot of sports growing up
and he would always beat me.
My dad would play the
sports that he was good at.
We would play tennis,
we would play squash,
we would play ping pong.
We never really played soccer.
Hm.
- I love my dad, he's
great, he's a big old nerd.
'Cause when people always
talked about how tall I was,
he'd say, "Yeah, he's grew-some."
You think your dad loves puns?
My dad invented puns.
I don't know a ton about
my dad's life before me.
The only thing I know is
that he is a mining engineer
and he was in a barbershop quartet called
the Four-Ever Yours.
(rimshot drumming)
I mean come on.
Music is really one of the biggest ways
that I think my dad and I have bonded.
So I thought if I was gonna
make anything of my dad,
I should make his iconic foursome
with my iconic foursome.
- How different the Try Guys
could've been, you know.
- When I was a kid, I really hated my dad.
He was never home.
He had to work about two hours away
so for a chunk of my childhood,
he was never there for five days a week.
Every time I saw my dad, he had to play
the disciplinarian role.
In retrospect, I feel really bad for him
because we did have a
lot of issues growing up
but I think a lot of it was just
the expectation of what a
man should be in his family.
And then my parents got divorced.
My dad versus Jae are
two different people.
Jae is the man that
came out of the divorce.
He became everything that I think
he was destined to be,
which is a good person
with a great sense of humor.
I'm very excited to learn
what this moment was
in this hammock where he's like,
dreamily looking up at that sky
that would warrant that smile.
When I was a child, I would never
see that expression on his face.
♫ Daddy, daddy, daddy, daddy
- So just be like, "Hey Adam."
Yeah, call me Adam.
- I'm Adam Kornfeld and I
am Zach Kornfeld's father.
Hi Zach.
I wanted to be in the music
business since I could remember.
I was eight or nine years old.
I used to listen to Casey
Kasem's American Top 40
and I was hooked.
- He loves rock n' roll.
I remember listening to the Beach Boys
and the Beatles and Bob Marley.
- I look like Freddie
Mercury's pudgier brother.
- I'm about the same age as you are now
in that photo.
I was on the beach on Fire Island.
One of my favorite places in the world.
Your grandparents actually met there
in the last 1950s.
That's a happy memory photo.
- I'm Jim, I'm Ned's dad.
And, then I don't know what
I'm talking about after that.
(laughing)
I've played practically every sport.
It's not as popular nowadays,
but in the 70s, tennis was huge.
- God, it's such an action shot.
We're like, jumping out at this.
We sometimes joke that I'm
really obsessed with marriage
but I think I get it from my dad.
He will do anything for his family.
- Every summer, in fact, I've never missed
a summer in my life,
with my dad and my mom,
we go to this place called
the Thousand Islands.
Crowds would come out to
watch these tournaments
that we'd have.
This photo is of me in
one of the tournaments.
(grunting)
- To the left.
You know, even just recreating
this in a photo studio
is tough.
I don't think I fully realized
how good at tennis my dad was.
- I know this smile of my dad's very well.
He has one smile.
- I'm Don Habersberger,
I'm Keith's father,
and he has two other sons.
Did I say that?
Let's start that all over.
I'm recently retired and I spent
over 40 years in the mining industry.
I was in choirs ever since fourth grade.
I began going to barbershop practices
and got into a quartet,
the Four-Ever Yours.
(rimshot drumming)
It's sort of a play on words.
Music was the part to
balance my life with.
♫ Sweet Adeline
- I'm Eugene's dad.
I was 41 years old when he was born.
Kinda old.
- I guess he's relaxed
now 'cause he's retired
but he had a pretty stressful life.
Even in this photo, I have no idea
if this was taken in Korea.
Growing up in a war torn country, I think,
does something to you.
- I kinda used to be dreamer.
All I was thinking about
was like a John Wayne
and cowboys, that's
all I was into, movies.
It wasn't like that
when I came to the U.S.
It's a very conservative country,
you have to work very
hard trying to make money.
Trying to support the family.
- For an asian family, and
for an immigrant family,
we don't share stories to begin with.
So to force my dad to come here
and talk about that stuff on screen
is pretty uncomfortable for both of us.
He seemed happier before he was a dad.
- I was so happy.
- [Zach] Hey dad.
- Hey Zach.
- How are you?
- I'm great.
- [Ned] Welcome to Buzzfeed.
- [Jim] Thanks.
- [Ned] This is where I work.
- Wow.
- Yeah, wow.
- Great shirt choice.
- I like yours, too.
- What would your normally
be doing right now?
- Playing golf.
- I don't really know about you in between
college and my birth.
The in between is like
really foggy and hazy.
- Yeah for me, too.
- (laughing) Yeah, I bet.
Show us that photo.
(laughing)
We got the same belly,
same chest hair pattern.
- So handsome.
- You're just saying that
'cause I look like you
in this photo.
- Yeah.
- [Zach] I have bigger nipples than you.
- Yes, bigger than most people.
I was probably listening
to Bruce in that picture.
- I should've known.
You are an east coast dad.
- Yes.
♫ Baby we were born to sit
- You and mom are both
like crazy workaholics.
I think that's why you
love the beach so much
'cause this is just like the only place
that you turn your brain off.
- That's true.
This is my weekend relaxation moment.
Your job, like my job, it's your life.
- Yeah.
- Sons being similar to their fathers.
- It's horrifying.
(laughing)
- Okay, let's see it.
- That's a good likeness.
That's a nice wig you got there.
- [Ned] Thank you.
- [Jim] Where'd you get the racquet?
I don't have those racquets anymore.
- Ariel had a racquet that she picked up
at a flea market.
- So this is during a tournament.
- Oh, a tournament?
This photo suddenly has
stakes that I didn't realize.
- Yeah
- Were you the reigning champion?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
So is that something the impressed mom?
- No, she isn't impressed
by that kind of stuff.
That's what I looked
like when I dated her.
- Oh.
(laughing)
She was into that.
- [Jim] What was her deal anyway?
I was very immature.
- [Ned] How so?
- I did some pranks.
I would get really frustrated easily.
As I've gotten older, I've gotten
more wise than I used to be.
- Hm, interesting.
I'm about to turn 30, y'all.
(laughing)
- Looking at the original photo,
I already look pretty similar.
So here's the new one.
- Oh.
- Look at that.
(laughing)
- Is it different?
- Right?
(laughing)
I'm definitely not adopted.
- We had a lot of outfits, I don't know
how many we had, but this outfit,
a few years later, was
what I was married in.
- I don't think I connected the two.
- Right.
And these were the ones
who were the best man
and ushers at the wedding.
After the wedding, we performed.
♫ Down our way
And the last song we performed was a song
called "The Auctioneer" and they auctioned
me off and Patty, your mom, got me.
She bid on me and got me.
- Did any other woman give
her a run for her money?
- No.
They wouldn't dare.
(laughing)
- Like one of them was
like, "I also bid on Don."
Our voices blend very well
because we have the same voice.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- These three guys are
part of my groomsmen,
so we decided we would Photoshop
all of us into your photo.
- Oh.
(laughing)
That's funny.
- [Eugene] So are you ready to see it?
- Sure.
- Alright, let's see it.
(laughing)
- Wow.
That's you?
- [Eugene] Yeah.
- [Jae] Just like me.
- Well I looked better than you.
- Yeah, that's true.
Can I start asking questions?
- [Man] Yup.
- Okay.
So where in Korea was this taken?
- No, it was in Houston, Texas.
- What?
Why were you in Houston?
- I was medical training.
- Where was mom?
- I didn't marry that time
until end of--
- You didn't move to America with mom?
- No.
I was single.
- You were single in America?
- Yeah,
for five years.
- You're single here?
- Yeah.
- You never listened.
- No, you never told me.
Did you have sex before mom?
Well there's a lot of girls.
- Wait, plural?
- Huh?
- More than one?
- Yeah.
- Were all of them Korean?
- No.
- What?
- That's not on video, right?
- No, it's all on--
(laughing)
What were you thinking
about in your photo?
- I was thinking about my future.
I changed a lot since I was a kid.
You know, I became person, I have to.
We went through a lot
of fertility clinics.
- Really?
- Yeah, I did a sperm test,
too, like you Try Guys.
- I didn't know you were
trying so hard to have kids.
It kinda explains a lot.
- We tried hold up the kid.
- What?
- Yeah, then she became pregnant.
It was the happiest day of my life
when my three kids came.
- Why haven't we talked about this before?
- Well anyways, you
know, we're getting old,
so nothing to hide.
- That's true.
- Alright, um, cool, dad.
Cool.
(laughing)
- I'm enjoying being a Try
Dad, I want you to know that.
- Try Dads.
- There's a lot more
because we've got four more,
you know this, yes you know, I told you.
- We're actually doing like a whole week
of videos with you, so
hold on tight, daddy.
- Alright.
(upbeat jazzy music)
- [All] Yeah!
- Oh.
I ripped my pants.
- [Keith] Uh oh.
- Right across the butt.
- Yeah I'm a cartoonist.
If you tell me a scenario,
I can draw you a cartoon
within a few seconds.
- [Keith] Oh man, I would
like to see a monkey
eating cheesecake at a fancy table.
- I can do that.